[موسيقى]
هذه المقاتله التي اشتهرت بين الطيارين في
القوات الامري
اعتبرت حينها اقوى المقاتلات الهجوميه هذا
بسبب قدرتها الكبيره في المناوره وكذلك
تحليقها لمدى بعيد يصل الى
1870 كلم
[موسيقى]
حيث تمكنت اليابان بفضل هذه المقاتله من
تحقيق سيطره جويه لفتره مهمه من الحرب كما
شاركت ايضا بالهجوم الشهير على ميناء
الامريكي
قد اضرارا جسيمه بالقوات الامريكيه
الموجوده في الميناء في هذا الوقت
[موسيقى]
هذا بجانب قدرتها على حمل قنبلتين كل
قنبله تزن نحو 60 كيلوغرام لكن في اواخر
يعني
1943 بدات موازين القوى تتغير لصالح
الحلفاء هذا بعد تمكن الشركات الامريكيه
من تطوير مقاتلات اسرع واقوى هذا الامر
افقد مقاتله الزيرو قوتها ورفع مستوى
خسائرها بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]